Speaker 1: Hi everyone. Today we have with us Shreya Bhojwani, Assistant Professor of Constitutional and Administrative Law at Nirma University in Hyderabad in Ahmedabad, sorry.
Speaker 1: Uh, thank you so much today for joining us, Shreya, and I hope this conversation brings perspective to renters who might be confused with the multitude of rental laws that we have in our country. So, um, I'll just proceed with my first question from here.
Speaker 2: Thank you so much for the introduction and thank you for having me. I hope I'll be of some use to you. So yeah, come on, let's put on some question and I'll try to answer the question.
Speaker 1: Yes
Speaker 1: Morning
Speaker 1: Thank you so much. So Shreya, my first question is about the Model Tenancy Act. So what is the 2021 Model Tenancy Act and how is it different from state-wise rent laws? Because in India we have different state-wide
Speaker 1: laws when it comes to renting. And if you could both give us a basic explanation of it as well as differentiate between state laws and the Model Tenancy Act.
Speaker 2: Okay. Let's explain what is the entire act about and what are these rules that each state government has been adopting for their respective states. So let's understand, let's start with Constitution of India. So Constitution of India under schedule provides different legislative power to the Union and the state government, right?
Speaker 2: So there's a list one which provides law making power to the union, which is the parliament of the country. List two provides the power to the state, which is the state legislature. Each state has the power to make laws.
Speaker 2: So with respect to land, with respect specifically when we are talking about tenancy and rent, state government has the powers or rather state legislature has the power to frame laws. So what happened is ki central government came up with Model Tenancy Act 2021 in June, June 2021.
Speaker 2: I'll give you a brief, you know, the need why this act was needed and why the central government came up with this, central parliament came up with this legislation. So you need to understand the concept of tenancy or rent is basically, you know, prevalent in urban India, not in rural India. So rural India ownership housing concept is there. There's no rent wala concept there.
Speaker 2: But in urban India, so because of migration, people trying to come out and work in different taking education, working, so they are coming out and trying to, you know, settle themselves in urban India wherein it is difficult to have ownership, house ownership.
Speaker 2: And rather seeing the pocket condition, it is very easy and friendly to you know rent out a place and start living there for employment opportunity or for educational opportunity. So government is trying through this legislation is trying to you know somehow create a balance between the rights of the tenant and rights of the landlord.
Speaker 2: And again, there are various schemes which the government is trying to incorporate and make, you know, bring all the legislation in parlance. I'll give you an example, jaise ki for instance, there's an economically weaker section or people with low income, low purchasing power, so they are not in a position to own a house. So for them, a government provide, government in India provide certain tax exemption.
Speaker 1: People
Speaker 1: So for them
Speaker 2: So if you are showing that I live in a rented property, you get certain exemption under tax laws. So yeah, so so being in in parlance with these legislation, government has come up with these this type of legislation which is called as Model Tenancy Act.
Speaker 2: Uh, what is this Model Tenancy Act? This Model Tenancy Act is generally, you know, the aim of the government with this legislation is first to regulate the entire rent ka concept, the tenancy concept in India. Secondly,
Speaker 2: Try to create a balance between the rights of the landlord and the tenant. Let's understand what I'm talking about, a balance between. So there has been a hustle.
Speaker 2: See, in India, tenancy has always been a concept of trust, wherein we just have a verbal interaction and I allow just based on the relations or maybe I find you good enough to stay at my property. So it is a trust ka concept in India.
Speaker 2: So I allow you to stay at my property. So we are, government is trying to enter into a written contract, make it a more formalized agreement.
Speaker 2: So it is trying to create a balance between when I say a balance between tenant and landlord so you need to understand there are certain concerns which the tenant has been facing in India like you know no clarity on amount of security that needs to be deposited so it is on the whims and fancicles of the of the tenant of the landlord that you have to deposit three months ka security amount maybe six months security amount so it has been clearly centralized it has been made common consensus has been made ki we have to deposit this month ka amount for as a
Speaker 2: security. Similarly, there has been concern from the side of landlord that tenants are not, you know, vacating their property, they are not paying rent. We cannot increase the rent amount. So all of these question has been answered through this legislation which is called as Model Tenancy Act.
Speaker 1: Not being
Speaker 2: So this act government aims through this act it aims ki boss they try to understand let's regulate the entire concept of tenancy in India and secondly try to create a balance between them and third if there's any sort of conflict between the tenant or the landlord there should be an adjudication process. So they're trying to bring out an adjudicator who can you know make them sit together the landlord and the tenant they can sit together and they can come to some sort of consensus. So it is also trying to bring out a adjudicatory framework.
Speaker 2: This is somewhat a model tenancy act. So it is, let's not call it a law, law per se, because again, it is some certain sort of framework because it is states prerogative to make laws for their own state. So state of Gujarat will make law for the Gujarat, the entire state, state of Maharashtra will make laws for state of Maharashtra itself.
Speaker 2: And so union has given a framework on the basis of which each state can make their own individual laws. So let's not call it a law law but it's type of a blueprint where it each it is it is on the state. The states are free if they want to adopt it as it is if they want to make any sort of modification they can completely do that.
Speaker 2: So there should not be any sort of comparison per se. So when the question number B that you asked was ki is there any sort of difference between Model Tenancy Act or State Legislation?
Speaker 2: Let's answer it in this manner, ki Model Tenancy Act is a blueprint, a bigger chart, a bigger framework and states are open to adopt it as it is or they can, you know, inculcate changes as per their own needs and requirements within the state. I hope I'm clear.
Speaker 1: Mali
Speaker 1: Yes, yes, very clear. So essentially Model Tenancy Act is not a blanket implementable law, it's more like a framework that states can follow.
Speaker 1: So ultimately, it's up to the states whether or not they want to adopt the Model Tenancy Act. And I'm assuming that not a lot of states in the country have fully adopted.
Speaker 2: Full
Speaker 2: So see, uh, what is the situation right now, Zoya, is that various states like Maharashtra, Karnataka, they have their legislation, rent control legislation.
Speaker 2: you know, dating 1990s, 1994, they already have their legislation. They are making amendments to it to meet the current requirement, but they have their own legislation. Some legislatures, like the state of Gujarat, also have its own rent control act, but it has amended the act to meet in parlance with the Model Tenancy 2021 Act.
Speaker 1: Okay, okay, okay. And this brings me to my second question which is somewhat related to it because there are nowadays there are reports going viral of new rent rules in 2026. There have been several reports.
Speaker 2: Okay
Speaker 1: And uh
Speaker 1: Are these new at all or are these just some provisions of the Model Tenancy Act that are circulating and how enforceable are these so-called rules? Is it fake news? I just wanted to debunk that because I've seen a lot of reels and a lot of news articles out there, you know, going on and on about these new rent rules. So if you could help us understand.
Speaker 2: See, using this term new rent rules per se, it is coming because of Model Tenancy Act 2021 itself.
Speaker 2: So I'll give you an example, like state of Gujarat from 1st April 2026 itself has made some changes, some amendment in its own legislation. The own the Gujarat Rent Control Act, which is a prior dated legislation before this Model Tenancy Act came into picture.
Speaker 2: So, the new rent rules are something which state government are adopting in conformity with the Model Tenancy Act. It is not some sort of new legislation altogether, but certain sort of amendment, certain sort of rules just to bring in conformity with the central legislation, the Model Tenancy Rules.
Speaker 1: Hello
Speaker 1: Okay, so it's still very much in process and it's not implementable in every state.
Speaker 2: No, haan, it is not. So if we talk about Gujarat, it is. So government has notified that it is with effect from 1st April, 2026. So now, suppose for instance, I'll give you certain example, Model Tenancy Act or now the Gujarat Act also says that ki it is a mandate ki if you want the tenant to vacate the property, you are supposed to give him a 3 month ka notice. So 13, 90 days notice, prior notice. For instance, if the maybe the tenant is requesting for certain essential repairs, it is a mandate on the landlord.
Speaker 2: Ki boss you are supposed to make those changes, make those repair done within 30 days.
Speaker 1: Government has not
Speaker 1: Okay
Speaker 1: Good
Speaker 2: So there are certain rules, jaise ki for instance it says, it is creating adjudication level at three different levels. So it is creating first the rent authority, the registrar authority, second the rent court, the rent tribunal, three levels of adjudication. So Gujarat government has adopted it. Now you you can approach with any sort of relief, it has to be solved within the timeline. 30 days timeline, 90 days timeline, 60 days timeline depending on the type of you know dispute that we are facing, the tenant or the landlord is facing. So it mandates like Model Tenancy Act mandates ki you
Speaker 2: need to get it registered. The rent agreement needs to be registered. So Gujarat government has adopted it. Within 60 days if you are transferring the possessory possession right over that property, you need to get it registered within 60 days.
Speaker 1: So there are
Speaker 2: So yeah, it has come in effect in state of Gujarat, but it is not the same situation for state of UP.
Speaker 1: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Okay, that's what I wanted to clarify most importantly because there are so many, you know, so-called legal professionals, you know, making videos, making it seem like it's a blanket rule for every state. So I think that knowing that demarcation is very important. So on to my third question.
Speaker 1: Uh, why are most rental agreements in India structured as 11-month agreements, and what legal protections does that structure remove or enhance for tenants?
Speaker 2: Okay
Speaker 2: Let's understand this. This is some sort of what I say, a tricky provision for, you know, Tenancy Act or for landlords and tenant situation in India. See, there's a legislation called as Registration Act, which is applicable in India. It is a very old legislation. I don't remember the year exactly, but yeah, there's a Registration Act which mandates that any sort of lease agreement happening between two parties, if it is of 12 months or above.
Speaker 2: needs to be mandatorily registered. So now, what is the loophole that we people have found is that it is 12 months or above. So now we have said we'll have a rent agreement of 11 months only.
Speaker 2: How it benefits us is that we save on, you know, a lot of time getting it registered before the registrar. We save a lot of time, a lot of money with respect to stamp duty, registration documents.
Speaker 2: So, it is some sort of flexibility that we have gained through this rent agreement, trying to escape through from registration act and you know, keeping a flexible condition between the landlord and the tenant. So hence this 11th you know, 11 months tenure has been decided just to escape registration act.
Speaker 1: Okay, okay, and does it remove any security for tenants or is it comparable? Okay.
Speaker 2: not comparable
Speaker 2: Not necessarily. See, it gets legalized once you get it registered via proper registration process, it gets legalized. It gets certain sort of evidentiary value before the court of law because it is registered before a registrar. So it is admissible in the court of law.
Speaker 1: Not necessary
Speaker 2: But saying that, it does not mean ki even a rent agreement ended between two parties without getting it registered, even a notarized document. It is just a stamp paper, a notarized document. It also have certain evidentiary value, but not in that high regard as that registered document because it has already become a government piece of document which is there with the registrar. But that doesn't means you you you might have to you know fight a lot to prove that, but you have legal recourse available for that also.
Speaker 1: Hmm
Speaker 1: just try.
Speaker 1: That is
Speaker 1: Ee
Speaker 1: Okay, so when tenants, just a follow-up question to this, if tenants want to rent, should they ideally push for the one year, two year rent agreements, or should they, you know, just make do with the 11 month rent agreement? Does it really make a lot of difference?
Speaker 2: See, it doesn't. For now it doesn't, but after this Model Tenancy Act, government is also pushing that it is better you enter into a written agreement. You come to because it can anyways be renewed. Even if you're getting a 11-month ka registration, you can renew it anytime you want. But the government is trying, don't enter into verbal agreement to renew it.
Speaker 1: But
Speaker 2: Get it registered, get it renewed on paper. So they are focusing on that, everything on written piece of paper.
Speaker 1: Mm-hmm
Speaker 1: everything on
Speaker 1: Got it, got it. Thank you. And um
Speaker 2: So sorry, so there's a lot of autonomy between the tenant and the landlord. It is totally how we the meeting of minds happen, how consensus or Adam is coming at picture, how we are meeting at mind. So we are agreeing at 11 months, total autonomy is given, government is not interfering in that. That is totally our call, how we want to enter into an agreement.
Speaker 1: of autonomy between
Speaker 1: Got it, Got it.
Speaker 1: And that brings me to my next question. Of course, not all properties are covered by state-wise rent laws. I come from Delhi and I was quite shocked to see that the rent legislation that is currently followed in Delhi is the 1958 Rent Control Act. There was one in the 1990s as well, but that was never implemented and the 1958 Rent Control Act only applies to you know, the pre-1990s.
Speaker 1: houses, pre-1988 houses. So, um
Speaker 1: Personally, I found it very confusing. So, if a tenant isn't protected by their own state's rent laws, then what essentially are they protected by? You know, they sign a rent agreement or they register it in court. So what kind of laws protect them or what kind of laws can they enforce? Yeah.
Speaker 2: Uh, let's understand. So, uh, these tenant, these rent agreements are special legislation, but there are certain general legislations which allow people to enter into contract, like Indian Contract Act.
Speaker 2: So through Indian Contract Act or laws like Transfer of Property Act, parties get this idea wherein they can enter into certain contract with related to their property, being a movable property or immovable property, like we have Sales of Goods Act. But when we are specifically talking about immovable property, Transfer of Property Act comes into picture.
Speaker 1: So through
Speaker 2: So wherein the act itself provides, provide ki how to enter into a lease agreement. What are the eviction rights? What is the rent right that a landlord gets? What is a, what are certain set of rights that a tenant get while entering into a lease agreement?
Speaker 2: So if you are not regulated by any specific legislation, there are legislation like Indian Contract or Transfer of Property Act which says that the contract should be on equitable terms, fairness principle should be followed, there should be meeting of mind, there should be consensus, a proper offer should be made, offer should be accepted, there should be a flow of consideration from both the sides, the duration should be specified, what are the set of rights that the person gets while entering into certain certain types of contract, what are set of duties that a person is supposed to abide by.
Speaker 2: by while entering into certain types of contract. So, see, there might not be a statutory law like Rent Control Act or like Model Tenancy Act, but you have remedy under different legislations and you can get it enforced through civil courts.
Speaker 2: So maybe you cannot go before a rent tribunal because you did not have a specific legislation but still you have remedy under civil courts and before the civil court you can get it enforced.
Speaker 1: Got it, got it. That really makes it very clear because it's honestly confusing how many laws exist in just one state for renting itself. And, let me just move on to the next one. Okay, so this would be my last question.
Speaker 1: Uh, what are some safe renting practices from a legal standpoint that tenants in India must follow, according to you?
Speaker 2: Okay
Speaker 2: Okay, so safe practices I would say first, let's enter into a written contract only, a written agreement only. Let's avoid this practice of verbal interaction because there's no clarity. So again from the point of evidence, written contract have more evidence free value than verbal contracts.
Speaker 2: Secondly, at the time when you enter into contract, it is very important for a tenant to verify ownership. Verify ownership means I should actually see the document that the property belongs to the landlord. So there should not be any sort of encumbrances on the property, which means there should not be prior liabilities over that property. I should verify that.
Speaker 2: Secondly, while entering into written contract, the amount, security amount which is the Model Tenancy Act says two months security should be mandated, not more than that. It should be very clear the rate at which and the year within which it can be increased. Every year if you are increasing, what what will be the rate within which it should be increased? Maybe
Speaker 2: a lock in period for tenant that the for landlord sorry lock in period for the landlord that the tenant cannot vacate the property before maybe six months or seven months so that the landlord do not have to go into this process of finding the new tenant for his own property. So yeah a lock in period can be recognized. Secondly maybe an adjudication clause should be there in case of any dispute where we are going to meet what is the place of forum where we can solve this problem. And maybe when you are moving in you should document
Speaker 2: into the entire property, you know, maybe taking a video clip or something of that sort, documenting the entire property becomes necessary. And lastly, I would say, when you're entering into a written contract, renewal term should be very clear that within what time period you must renew it.
Speaker 1: Okay. Got it. Thank you so much Shreya for joining us and I hope the community can find our conversation useful and can benefit from it while renting.
Speaker 2: Joining us
Speaker 2: And can